ma numero 14 incredibilmente la canzone
del natale è disco d'oro che uno dei
temi cene riflessione da fare è favoloso
come tagliare su un microfono mi abbia
resa una star internazionale sono
proprio felice mi sento appagata io ho
capito qual è il vero senso della mia
esistenza bongiorno luce dei miei occhi
come ti senti ora che sei una star
internazionale della musica dove sei
secoli ma bene direi molto faticoso non
so se potete utilizzare questi mattoni
parlate col mio manager giorno
buongiorno buongiorno del giorno vale
comunque sono le 11 11 valeri gare di
svuotare la lettiera prepara la
colazione per tutti che ho fatto per
sbaglio la cacca e mezzo la mia stanza
io ci tenevo a ringraziare tutti quanti
fan della nostra musica la canzone del
natale postato ieri e già disco d'oro
questo grazie ai nostri ascolti quindi
continuate a stream mar l'art quanto di
piattaforme digitali noi è un piacere
dividere
la nostra anima con con voi grazie a
tutte le persone che hanno notato poi la
cura nei dettagli il pezzo tutte le
piccole chicche le attenzioni
spero che possa arrivare tanta
tantissima altra musica di mirtilla come
ci si sente ad aver realizzato un disco
d'oro in sole 24 ore felici
c'è sempre margini di crescita si può
arrivare alle 12 ore obiettivo è quello
di avere un disco d'oro di una canzone
che ancora non ha nemmeno uscita il
talento della discografia faccio
un'altra punta
vado più alto il disco d'oro ieri solo
l'inizio io sto lavorando ad altri
progetti 100.000 like se volete sentire
le pd famiglia nati per essere questo
successo che ho trovato sta scrivendo
sicuramente una canzone non disturbarmi
tener a mente dell'artista che veda ci
sto ecco come produce un vero artista
[Applauso]
forza la creazione di un capolavoro in
diretta quasimodo non giocare con quello
scontrino da zona mamma te lo compra
d'oro non lo so proprio il disco d'oro
ma guarda come n'era accorta per niente
star internazionale
il disco d'oro
il pezzo di arrivare in camera con la
mascherina ziglioli cavallo deserto lo
stesso si ho capito che non posso
sprecare tutta la mia vita c'è troppo da
letto da donare alla fuori porge loro
look grigia marra che sta girando un
film fronte giorni abbiamo in lui fare
stare alla grande e che vorrebbe state
harry per la tua arte c'è piccolo guscio
che vorrebbe lavorare con piccolo lucio
in quantità che invece ha chiamato
nessuno rimarrà volentieri ma corretto
nel mio manager mi dica caro
ma come fai umile che nonostante la
popolarità continua a fare la fila
panorama riprende di giornalisti possono
parlare di quanto sono rimasto ancora
jenny from the block per io sono
semplicemente rimasto me stesso
quello che facevo prima continuo a farlo
ma battuta ora libero sei veramente una
persona di cuore e molto umile in suolo
enoturisti siete pronti a vedere la
discografia in realtà cosa nasconde tu
non lo stai facendo davvero non mi
voglio vivere il ricordo di tanti veli
di tutte le star di quest'estate che
cosa è successo e io mi diverte molto
fare delle foto che avete cose che così
artistica è venuto pure widow facciamo
una foto noi tre e lei 33 anni avere una
torta di be pilota è il mio migliore
amico di 27 anni guido con me a
festeggiare a mitica se il mio posto
preferito non potrei chiedere di meglio
e vi 00 io andrò ha calcolato menzione
la mia opinione di valentina è cambiata
da così a così posso fare una riga salva
il fiato per spiegare quello che stiamo
per ascoltare
[Musica]
tanti bar
la vita
già il manierismo per me sono di porre i
nomignoli norme carriera al milan
e tu pensavi di competere con crik crok
la prima decisione di click proprio
com'era chiamatemi se ne avete bisogno
[Musica]
natale un cazzo scritto ptc like se
volete l'extended version di crik crok
il mio singolo dopo anti line mettetela
in che sentiamo di acam è toccato il
confessionale con guido so che tutti
quando escono leggono illuminate
effettivamente sento una luce divina che
mi sta facendo dire qualcosa disagio e
pepe sei andato cercando la mia veste la
veste che mi ha fatto sfondare
nell'animo schermo me l'ha nascosta
perché teme il mio ufficio è generato
della tua fama e invidioso dove la pezza
ecco le ho già fatto di elmo novella
terrestre o nella spesa all'hard rock
cafe di roma 1 st scomodo il mio
successo
tallinn banca che la gente che voleva
votato dio d'europa di esposizione
mediatica
sono circondato da persone mi vergogno
un po parlare con cui cretino al
telefono e non so se ti succede anche a
parlare qualcun altro al posto mio
forse è vista da fuori che volle questa
cosa va vabbè il buco che ci sono due
cose non sopporto più in questa casa dei
pallini divorate dal punto dunque un
pene unam siamo l'albero con le palline
solamente anno perché i gatti che fanno
vedere è un circolo vizioso cartier canu
fatevi ma insieme la polvere che si
annida in questa dimora va bene tutto
tutto ok ma dov'è la mia veste
questa che è la mia essere molto del mio
pc come questa convivenza
oltre alla sua pappa mangiare anche il
cibo dei gatti è una grande conquista in
testa a sfondare presti dalla faccia
dire proprio di sì e io come curdo un po
il cibo di caldo io sono niente in
realtà sommato figurative dove mike era
una cosa del genere è come non essere
stati inclusi nella canzone come ci si
sente che offeso non ne vuole proprio
parlare c'è da dire una cosa cioè tu
canti un cane passando se io impazzendo
dove minchia questa veste
e c'è chi s'è già montata la testa
no ragazzi e grazie all'auto giugno e
che ci andiamo infilato ho appena
incontrato una ragazza dolcissima
carissima ma ha salutato mi sono reso
conto che in questo momento no ai suoi
casi si presta molta più attenzione le
piccolezze dei dettagli spero che non si
perda per il venga dettata appunto dal
periodo
il tutto questo è un grido fuori da un
rene sa fa male al ginocchio abbiamo gli
altri che fanno a fare ramo che la casa
non sia esplosa e cosa si prepari e come
spero di essere contattato almeno da
importante ristorante andate ad aprire
il catering è andato li caccio uno
spuntino delle tartare vogliamo fare
tutorial fate la porta a porta
no ti prego bene si veda mi cercano
posso dire che non ho ripreso poi il
colpo di pozzo ci sei mai
no c'è nei preparate già due con tutto
il tempo che richiede la preparazione
fatta ragazzi ma guardatelo del
capolavoro cioè dell'anno piatto sarebbe
già finito così un pre voglio fare
ancora di più
dovrebbe farmi un favore chiunque va giù
a fare la spesa deve portarmi su un po
di terriccio devo piantare la palla e di
galleria collo lo pensiamo qua dentro di
un uomo distrutta senza casa sono dei
piatti gourmet governo albero è questa
la mia voce è questa la mia voce e va
bene un po troppo non ci credo
stavo scendendo per prenderà la terra
c'è basilico
ma perché siamo con due telecamere che
il peso st basilico un caso da me ma
tutto bene tenete utili e non ci sono i
gatti fanno cadere le palle ogni via
quel bastone rivestiti da umano
allora ora brutta notizia da dare al
calcio sempre fuori di me se io bianco
melli qui dentro potrebbe non farcela
perché no o il basilico manager cioè non
può succedere montanelli in un altro
modo
chiediamo allora come possiamo darvi
darne in un altro modo dobbiamo prendere
la strada non ci andiamo a prendere a
terra campana ragazzino che gli
escrementi bovini nei nostri piatti e
gianmarco tutti
sei fuori da questa cosa fare per fare
questo piatto ma che condita però un po
di pepe sulla data se non credo ci sia
il pepe ma ragazzi
vai a mano e non appaga e appena fatto
cascare vale per te ha però rimarcato
oggi metterà seriamente in difficoltà
gabriella il suo accampando ma che sono
dichiarazioni force sta bleffando
scodare che stanno avventista molto
troppo la destra monetario nel film e le
noccioline
ciao forse ci sarebbe pure bene un
pizzino dimostra una buona philadelphia
miele e nutella è il matrimonio del
secolo si non sarà bellissimo granella
questo stato niente in cui 10 teoria che
il delizioso stiamo scendendo a friend è
un po di terra x men ma quindi sai dove
stiamo andando
dobbiamo andare a cercare adesso dei
vasi prendere della tegola di già vedeva
ti guarda non ci credo è tornato
dove sei stata tutto questo tempo hite
rimpiazzate con me siamo per rubare
della terra da questo vaso e legale
rubare della terra di terra facciamo in
fretta
agisci in fretta
ma la terra da devo compattare chiamano
faccio una chiamata lui le sa queste
cose cioè non basta questa donne serve e
che ne so una palla lo so pronto q ma
alla terra deve essere compattata o no
abbiamo trovato una sede è tornato ora
vedrà sarà una sorpresa a cartuccia la
devo mettere questa palla e sa che lato
perché qui vedo che c'è una punta
sottosopra la punta e direi di infilarla
come tutto nella vita cioè la punta si
infila però che se una pianta e a carte
sarà metteresti io la metterei al centro
vogliamo farlo nel lavandino questo
lavoro ce l'ha messo ecco ha dentro
annaffiamo e aspettiamo
quanto tempo ci vuole per un'ora acqua
calda o fredda acqua ambiente quanta
acqua è ben a bella botta alla quaglia
da rave e dagli vita ok però c'è un
problema non dovremmo fargli un buco
sotto al bicchiere per far uscire
l'acqua anche quella viene servita tutta
cioè tutti qualsiasi vaso ha un buco
sotto
vabbè al petto memora come potrebbe
farlo crescere se con la consapevolezza
e non crescerà mai nulla all'interno di
quel bicchiere piccola facciamoglielo
credere io vi saluto coperto dal mio né
gocciolo carino che ha tolto di forza
imposto a lei prepotente sei proprio mio
figlio anche se io non amo chiamare gli
animali figli o preferisco i termini
coinquilini se proprio il mio
coinquilino totalmente ci vediamo domani
alle 14 con un altro club ma